so welcome everybody to the webinar
today about risk management
i am going to share with you lots of
tips and tools for how you can become
excellent at managing risks
but you will see the word leader in here
as well it is for project leaders and
that means that we will very much look
at how you can become a leader in this
process
this is about risk management for
project leaders
basically i'm going to share with you
today
lots of tips and tools for how you can
become
really really good at managing risks but
not just managing risks i want you to
walk away from today's webinar with some
real leadership tips because risk
management is not just about going
through the motion and ticking boxes
that can be absolutely useless i want
you to apply thought and consideration
and leadership to the process
what i'm going to cover we're going to
look at what a risk is
just a brief introduction then i'm going
to take you through step by step the
nine step risk management process from a
to z really we're also going to cover
some of the most common mistakes in risk
management i want to ensure that you
don't make those mistakes so that you
can go on
manage your projects and make sure you
don't have issues turn up
then i'm also going to share with you
how you can lead a risk management
workshop
many project managers shy away from
leading workshops i want to make sure
that's not you so i'm going to give you
some tips for how to lead it when we run
workshops in collaboration with the team
you get much better engagement and it
takes some of the pressure off your own
shoulders because they're going to share
with you the process
and then we're going to finish off with
what your own risk attitude is but i'm
gonna leave that
till the end to explain what that is
i would like you all to become clear on
what you would like to learn from this
webinar
and have pen and paper with you and
write down what you want to get from it
maybe you find that you're one of those
who often end up assigning yourself to
most of the risks
if that happens it's definitely a clear
sign that you have something to learn
because risks shouldn't just be owned by
the project manager
a little bit about myself before we go
on
i have 20 years of experience leading
change programs mainly in the financial
services sector in between technology
and the business
i've written two books one is the
project management coaching workbook and
the other one is the power of project
leadership it came out a year ago and
i'm delighted to tell you that it is
being translated into chinese
for the last three years i have been
a full-time coaching
project managers training project
managers and running workshops in
project leadership and risk management
if you would like to know more please
visit my website suzannematson.com
actually on my website there is a
resources page where you can sign up for
free to get all of my resources
including some of the risk management
templates like a risk log that i'm going
to share with you today so please don't
miss out on that it is completely free
just go to the website
suzannematson.com
so the first question and this is where
i realized no one was listening because
i got had no responses
now please can i have your responses in
the chat box which one of these is a
risk is it number one we might not have
enough budget
is it number two we can't meet the
deadline is it number three the project
is using untested technology or is it
number four the organization does not
use sponsors
oh we have lots of people saying number
three the product is using autistic
technology you're wrong it is not number
three
please try again
all of the above one is saying
no only one of these is a risk and it is
not number three
this is interesting isn't it we're
getting all kinds of responses okay let
me help you out
number one is a risk we might not have
enough budget why is that because risks
are items that may happen we might not
have enough budget we don't know but we
might not that's that's a risk
number three and number four the project
is using artistic technology the
organization does not use sponsors
they're written in present tense they're
statements
they might lead to risks but they're not
in themselves risk their statements they
could cause risks but they're not
risks always begin with something that
might happen or could happen or is
probable
number two we can't meet the deadline to
me that sounds like an issue it is
something that is a problem right now
so what is the difference well at risk
is uncertainty
that matters as it says here bullet
number two
it is really an uncertain event that if
it occurs has a positive or negative
effect on objectives that means that
risk may not happen they may happen we
don't know there is a probability of it
happening from between
1 and 99
whereas issues
they have already happened
it is something that is currently
impacting the project that means that
issues have a probability of 100
they are already there you having to
deal with them
there are two dimensions of risk one of
them is probability as i just mentioned
another word for probability is
likelihood it is exactly the same thing
how likely or unlikely is the risk to
happen
if i say to you it will rain tomorrow
i don't know
my iphone tells me there's a 50
likelihood you know i live in london so
it rained it has rained here several
times today
and
but is that a risk
it might rain tomorrow there's a 50
probability
well it depends what i'm gonna do
tomorrow if i'm going to stay indoors
and and write a project report it has no
impact on me at all so
it doesn't really matter
but if i'm telling you that there's
going to be a snowstorm tomorrow and you
are having to go to work
then i'm sure it's a risk to you because
it could impact your journey the other
dimension of risk is impact
in case the risk happens there will be
an impact or an effect on the project's
objectives
that impact could be positive or
negative
because risks can actually be positive
as well as negative
most normally we talk about
negative risks something bad will happen
that could prevent your project from
moving forward
and that's the majority of the focus of
today's webinar but there is such a
thing as positive risks we also call
them opportunities
that's when something happens and it may
even have a positive impact
imagine for instance that you
are
launching a new website to sell a new
product there is a risk
that
it's over subscribed
and that you won't have enough products
to send out
but actually there is an opportunity
here because if you put more stock if
you if you gather more stock you could
actually sell more if you are prepared
for this risk that you might sell out so
you see that there could be we can some
with sorry with positive risks it's
about leveraging the opportunity when we
come to looking at risk management in
more detail later about how to how to
mitigate it we need to look at both
probability and impact we need to lower
the probability and lower the impact in
case the risk happens but why does all
of this matter in the first place
why do we care about risk management
well we care because it's all about
avoiding issues
to happen later in your project for
instance
if we say there is a risk
that our
technology isn't going to work because
we use new technology so there's a risk
so let's say we are using untested
technology hence there is a risk that we
might be late because there could be
unforeseen work involved if we do
nothing about that then it could turn
out to be an issue and it could delay
your project but if you do something
about it you could prevent it from
happening so that's really why we care
you see on projects there are lots of
issues all the time we have scope creep
we have disharmony on a team the team is
not pulling their weight we have lots of
defects all of these issues
are very likely to be as a result of not
having looked at what could go wrong and
not having mitigated the risks in
advance
so we're now going to go through the
nine step risk management process i'm
just going to tell you now what the nine
steps are
and then we're going to go into them in
more detail
one by one the first step is to identify
risks and also opportunities that means
positive as well as negative risks
then we need to analyze the root causes
because otherwise it becomes difficult
to do something about it then we need to
determine impact and determine
probability only then can we decide on
what to do what are the risk responses
that we're going to do that we're going
to take and who is going to own them the
risk responses and the risks then it's
about documenting risks this is where we
have a risk log we need to communicate
risks
at in weekly status report meetings and
steering committee meetings and finally
we need to review
what we're doing regularly this is the
overview of the process we're now going
to go into it in more detail because
there's a lot to say about each of these
and we have to remember
that we're not just doing the process we
want to be leaders not just managers
so let me just remind you of the
differences between management and
leadership
management is where we just
i'm saying just but there is a big need
for managers but this is more about
processes doing things right
um calculations so in a risk management
context it's about locking the risks
and
you know
following the process of risk management
but leadership is much more people
oriented it's about bringing people with
you it's about embedding a risk culture
into your team it's about making sure
that it's the right people who own the
risks it's about making sure that it's
the right actions we're taking against
the risks i don't care if you have a
risk register i care
about whether you have the right risks
logged whether you're doing something
useful about the risk and whether the
right people are owning them
so a big part of being a leader here is
to engage people with risk workshops as
we're going to talk about later on and
that you really take a step back and
look at all the risks
aggregated as well what does this tell
me yeah so it's really about being
mindful and applying some thought into
the process
let's go back to step number one of the
risk management process about
identifying risks and opportunities how
do we do that
well i propose that you organize risk
workshops i'm gonna tell you later on in
the webinar how to do that ask people
what they worry about if you ask people
what risks can you think of sometimes
their mind goes blank they're not really
sure but if you ask people what do you
worry about what could stop us from
moving forward what could go wrong oh
they can definitely answer those
questions so maybe sometimes you need to
rephrase your questions to make sure
that people think differently about this
if you sit down in isolation and list
out all the risks that might happen on
your project
chances are that
you're not going to be as thorough as if
you engage the entire team also when you
engage the entire team you get buy-in
from them and it's easier to have other
people help you to own the risks that
way you can begin to create a risk
culture it shouldn't just be the project
manager carrying this so risk workshops
super super important
um as you do the risk workshops you can
also use risk lists to prompt you to to
look at what
might go wrong yet there are lots of
standard risk lists out there on the
internet
and also involve people from outside the
project
why might you want to invite or involve
people from outside the project into
your risk workshop
i'll tell you why because your team has
limited knowledge
people outside of your team
have more knowledge
maybe you're running a project that your
team hasn't tried before but someone
else has done a very similar project if
you invite them into your risk workshop
they can help you look at risks that you
hadn't even thought about we call those
the unknown unknowns
when you sit down and you identify all
the risks that could have on your
project
what you are really identifying are the
known unknowns it's the risks that you
know about
but so welcome everybody to the webinar
today about risk management
i am going to share with you lots of
tips and tools for how you can become
excellent at managing risks
but you will see the word leader in here
as well it is for project leaders and
that means that we will very much look
at how you can become a leader in this
process
there are risks that you don't even know
about
they come in from the left field and you
didn't even see them we sometimes call
those for black swans
you can
really work with them
and help mitigate them by inviting
outsiders into your project to help you
see what you don't see
and then remember in your risk workshop
to also look at positive risks what are
the opportunities here
what are what are the opportunities that
we can leverage in case they happen
so that's step number one identify
anything that could go wrong or any
opportunities that if we don't do
something about it now we're gonna miss
out on that opportunity
i would like to ask you to type into the
chat box which risks you feel we often
forget about on a project i'm keen to
hear your views
which risks are often forgotten about in
your experience
please type your answers
communication
test system scope creep human factors oh
i like that one
uh vadim
human factor absolutely we often forget
about that one
ignoring the stakeholders end-use impact
that's very interesting yes we often
ignore those risks
procurement hardware again human factors
politics
oh we have everything here monetary
issues
yeah i find people mostly identify those
but involving our stakeholders you
mentioned great one
that's often forgotten about
vendor management again
non-technical risks
oh excellent you have lots of stuff
coming up here
now
um i agree with all of those
in in my experience and you will see
here the swing on on the um on the uh
in the overview here the the image sorry
um the customer wanted a a swing with
three tears on it that's what they
explained
i think we often are quite good at
identifying this risk that the team
might design it wrong you know so we can
do things about that but what we don't
often see is that the customer needed
something completely different
we so caught up in what the customer
says they want us to deliver we get so
caught up in specifications we forget to
ask ourselves is it the right
specification
is there a risk here that the customer
doesn't know
what they need
yes there is a risk
but most teams in my experience forget
about it
another risk and i'm very pleased you
mentioned it here is the human aspects
you know people fall out working
relationships break down people miss uh
interpret contracts that have been
written they fall out over that
but how many wrist locks have you seen
where we actively go in and mitigate
people-related issues or risks early on
as you're saying here
the human side of it so i'm very pleased
that some of you are mentioning that i
don't want to see risk locks just with
technical risks than them i want to see
real wrist blocks what is it really that
could prevent us from moving forward
what is it that could derail this
project yes human factors absolutely but
what are we going to do about it
the second step is to identify the root
cause and you'll see here that we have a
fish bone diagram that will help us to
work backwards
and find out what really causes
this
risk
keep asking why
but why
and i'll give you an example let's say
you have a risk on your project that a
key team member
may leave the company you've heard
someone talk about it
joe
may lead the company he's jump hunting
oh when you start panicking oh my god
what's the likelihood 50 80 but for sure
it's a risk
what are you going to do about that
well
you could do a number of things you
could make sure that he writes
documentation you could make sure that
uh you line someone else up so that if
joe leaves then you have someone else
who can take over but you see that is
not addressing the root cause
if you ask what's really the reason why
joe might want to leave if you go and
have a conversation with joe
you might find out that joe
doesn't feel that he gets enough variety
or autonomy in his job
he doesn't like the working conditions
he doesn't like his salary or whatever
else it is that's what you really need
to address if you want to keep him on
board
uh it may not you know if you just line
and up another person you have not
addressed the root cause joe might leave
you can hand over to another team member
that means that you lessen the impact
but you're not
you're not fundamentally avoiding this
risk from happening so if you always
understand the root cause of your risks
it will be much easier for you to
actually choose the best mitigating
strategy and to really find out what you
can do about it
the
third and the fourth step
is
to look at the impact and the
probability of each of the risks that
you have identified the worst risks of
course are those with a high probability
and a high impact in the top right hand
corner with a dark color what you'll see
in the
top left hand side is something with a
low probability and a high impact
this is risks that might not happen but
if they happen oh boy they're going to
have a big impact for instance
it's very unlikely that something will
happen to your building your physical
building
like uh the building disappears there's
an explosion there's a bomb hitting it
or whatever it's very unlikely if it
happens
then it's going to have a major impact
for instance when the twin towers in new
york went down many years ago now
that is why most companies have disaster
recovery they have backup plans they
have contingencies
in case something happens to your site
and to your data there's a very low
probability but the impact is so high
that we do something about those risks
on the other end of the spectrum here
towards the
bottom right hand side you have
something with a high probability and
low impact this means that yeah
there's a risk that people might leave
your project for instance
it's quite let's say it's quite
likely this has a high probability but
it has low impact because you have other
people who can take over let's say
that is
much
easier to deal with than something that
has a high impact so you really must be
aware of risks with a high impact the
other thing that we sometimes do is that
you can identify risks lots of risks
some of them have low probability low
impact but you're not going to do
something about all of them
you can draw
your risk profile here with the red line
and say that anything
towards the top right hand corner of
this red line you're going to do
something about the other ones you're
going to accept
where this red line is drawn will depend
on your risk appetite the risk appetite
of the company the organization
and or the risk appetite of your project
the question you are asking is
how much risk are we ready to take
and can we afford for something to go
wrong
if you're working the aircraft industry
if you're working for boeing
or for airbus chances are that this red
line doesn't exist
because they cannot afford for anything
to go wrong so the risk appetite is very
very
and this red line will be right down in
the
left hand corner bottom left hand corner
on the other hand if you're working for
a hedge fund which are those financial
institutions that take lots of risk
well their risk appetite is going to be
very high so this red line will be very
much towards the upper
right hand side of this matrix it means
that they're going to accept most of the
risks they're going to deal with it if
it happens
my guess is that most organizations have
a risk profile in between
somewhere where i have drawn it right
now
so this is very useful to find out
and to decide with your team what are we
going to do which risk are we going to
address and which risks are we not going
to address what is our risk appetite are
we going to do something about even our
minor risks or only something about our
top risks when you look at the impact of
a risk
well the impact on what well what's the
impact of a risk on time cost quality
that's really what you need to ask
does it impact materially the success
criteria of the project
so let's go back to this untested
technology again there is a risk
that because we're using autistic
technology our project could be late
because there may be unforeseen issues
with it that means that it could impact
time it could impact cost because we
might have to throw more people at it or
find better technology
it could even impact quality because we
don't know it's really a risk here
so for sure that's the impact look at
the impact on time cost quality but
that's not all you also need to look at
the other triangle
this is more the strategic triangle the
business case triangle does this risk
impact
the effect that the project is the
project's effect on the strategic
objectives
so what do i mean by that every project
has an effect on strategic objectives or
should have strategic projects
have strategic objectives
if your risk is impacting the strategic
objectives then it's quite serious also
is your risk impacting the relevance to
the users
any good project that has a good
business case
is delivering something that's relevant
to the users is your risk making your
product or your project less more or
less relevant and the last one is
sustainability is this risk impacting
sustainability of your product
so you see this top triangle is really
about the business case of the project
it's about delivering value not just
delivering time cost quality
so when you assess the impact of a risk
you need to assess the impact on all of
these six dimensions this fifth sorry
the fifth step
after you have identified root causes
and determined impact and probability of
every risk
is to decide on the risk responses
these are the standard risk responses
that we have out there according to the
pm buck
you can reduce a risk
avoid it accept it share it and transfer
it
when you transfer a risk it really means
sometimes that you take out um
you can have a partnership with a with a
vendor you can write a contract meaning
that they
if something happens then they take on
the risk if you take out an insurance
for instance you're really transferring
the risk to the insurance broker
if you have a partnership
you can share risks with a partner
but i think the most common risk
responses are actually to reduce the
risk
and we can look at um
and an example for instance if you're
planning to run an outdoor event let's
say you're planning to run
an outdoor concert and there is a risk
of rain
now what can you do to reduce the risk
of rain well that's a hard one isn't it
but you could move the event to a region
where it's less likely to rain um
you can also reduce the impact in case
it does rain what would you do to reduce
the impact well you could hand out
embryo umbrellas you could hand out
ponchos so you see when we reduce
at risk we need to look at reducing the
impact as well as the likelihood that's
very important to get that
don't just reduce the impact no also
look at the root cause and and actually
look at how you can reduce the
likelihood of this risk happening you
can avoid the risk of rain for your
outdoor concert by having it indoors or
you can simply accept it
on the right hand side you see the risk
responses to opportunities that we also
call positive risks this is all about
exploiting a risk making it more likely
to happen because you want to reap the
positive benefits
all right
the sixth step is to assign owners now
that you have decided what you are going
to do about each of your risks this is
where i see many project managers go
wrong because they simply assign
themselves to the risks
they feel that just because they're the
project manager they should deal with
the risk
but that's not true you must assign the
right owner for each risk
make sure that this owner accepts
responsibility
one of the best ways for doing that is
making sure that people are part of
deciding who to own each risk it
shouldn't just be you as a project
manager deciding who owns what no decide
this in collaboration the seventh step
is to document your risks
this is a standard risk
risk log that you see
out there you can log your risks with a
unique identifier the date
category is something to do with
resourcing technology it will really
just help you to
filter for the risks afterwards
you put in the risk description
and the probability an impact is at high
medium low you can also use scales from
one to five or one to three
who is the owner and what is the risk
response
what are we going to do about this risk
and what's the date for when we're going
to take action
as i said earlier on you can log on to
my website and download this risk list
simply go to my resources page and
register for free
the eighth step is very important this
is about communicating risks
this is again where leadership comes in
you have to be able to
show that you are a leader that you're
not afraid of talking about the things
that could go wrong on your project
i recommend that you include the top
five risks in your weekly reporting and
also in the monthly steering committee
pack
that you're hopefully putting together
for your steering committee
make sure you discuss what these risks
are
what is really what could really hit us
here do i need any of the senior
managers help in addressing some of the
major risks
and by the way always communicate big
risks in person to your stakeholders
if you just write
you know a big risk in in a report and
send it out and that's where they see it
for the first time
that is really something you should
avoid do not make that mistake make sure
that you see people in person or that
you call them to talk through something
important that's happening
you know what we say managers don't want
issues presented to them they want
solutions
so yes you do need to talk about risks
but you do need to show that you've
thought about what you're going to do
about it
you are simply running your risk
responses by the most senior executives
to make them feel comfortable and to i
suppose get that buy-in for what you're
doing about some of the major risks that
could hit your project
of course if you are doing something
major to address a risk
that could um that will is going to cost
more let's say we're going back to our
autistic technology again what might you
do to reduce the risk of
your untested technology impacting the
project
well
you could run a prototype
uh you could do a demo or yeah run a
working prototype well that might cost
us more to do that
then you need to ask for extra money
to implement this risk mitigation
strategy that's some of the things that
you need to get approval for from your
product board
i hope that makes sense some of your
risk risk responses actually requires
that extra funding or extra time is set
aside
the ninth step is to regularly regularly
review your risks
i see far too many project managers
creating a risk register
and then they never look at it again
but that is utterly pointless risks will
keep cropping up on your project so you
need to keep having risk workshops and
keep reviewing your wrist blocks and
asking the team what could go wrong and
what are we going to do about it have
res have your review meetings with the
team
also set time aside in your own diary to
look at what could go wrong routinely
ask people what they worry about and
what opportunities they see
as i said before you might not want to
use the word risk because people don't
always connect with the word risk if you
ask them what risks they see
ask them what they worry about ask them
what was holding them what could be
holding them up
now a question for you for the chat box
what are we going to do about the
unknown unknowns
that means the risks
that you haven't thought about
i actually gave you the answer a little
bit earlier on in the webinar let's see
if you remember
do we have any suggestions
management reserve yes we can actually
set contingency budget aside
for the unknown unknowns in case
something happens we can have
contingency or management reserve for it
contingency plan people are saying
mitigate
oh yes and someone is saying bring in
outside outside eyes that's exactly
right help other people to identify the
things you haven't been able to identify
yourself
because
things are only risks because we haven't
seen them coming other people might see
them and might say to you know what i
ran a project like this in the past um
have you thought about this and that
could go wrong and you go oh my god we
hadn't even thought about that
so that reduces uncertainty by inviting
other people in
and yes what you're saying management
reserve contingency plans so uh you
absolutely
nailed it
oh it's great to see work around it's
great to see all of your
all of your comments
so what are the most common mistakes
that i see in risk management i would
like all of you to say that wow you're
not making these mistakes that would be
fantastic okay mistake number one
treating risk management as a mechanical
process where we just have a risk
register and we think that we've done
risk management well by just filling in
the risk register
that could
that is so far from the truth as i hope
that today's webinar is showing you
there is much more to it much more
thought we need to put into it planning
in isolation and not drafting in the
team you have to and i cannot emphasize
this enough
risk management is a collaborative
effort you want to create a risk culture
in your organization and in your team
where everybody's thinking about risks
where everybody's owning the risks and
where we naturally mitigate them it
should not just be the project manager
doing this the way you change that
culture is by running risk workshops
which i'll show you
on the next
slide how to run those risk workshops
also not assigning old whole owners to
the risks or holding them to account do
not just assign yourself to the risks
it is not the most effective as a
project manager you are monitoring the
process you are not owning all of the
risks
again collaborative risk workshops where
you
have people volunteer to own risks is a
really good way of doing this
if the risks cannot be owned by the team
but need to be owned by senior
management
then take them to your sponsor and say
who is the best person to own this risk
i feel that is beyond our team we need
some someone higher up to help us own
this risk do not try to hide it it shows
leadership that you can bring that to
the attention of senior management
not considering positive risks or people
risks
we talked about this before
people i mean projects are full of
people and
you know if just we didn't have people
it would be much easier wouldn't it uh
because people create trouble
and people are irrational and people
have emotions and people fall out
so
it's very important that you consider
when you start up your project
what
what's the real risk here do i have
different cultures involved um
do we have different vendors involved do
we have difficult stakeholders what am i
going to do to mitigate
any people related issues what can i do
to create more more trust in the team so
that we avoid
uh people-related issues
what can we do to create better better
bonding
and better collaboration
and positive risks
look at your team at the opportunities
what are the positive things that could
happen here what might happen what
what opportunities might occur that if
we are not ready for them we cannot reap
them
very important to ask that question i
think this angle is overlooked
we only always think about the negative
things that might happen but
what about the positive things what
about new technology that might come out
in the process
if we're not ready for new technology we
can't leverage that opportunity so
that's a really good example of a
positive risk
not considering unknown unknowns
we talked about that
as we said put put aside contingency for
the unknown unknowns and invite
outsiders into the team to help you
identify some of the risks that you
cannot see yourself
okay another one here not looking at the
overall risk profile so
if you have all of your risks listed in
your risk log let's say you have
20 risks
you can do something about each
individual item you can mitigate each
risk
if you look at the collective of all of
these risks you may see a different
pattern
and you may come to see that actually
putting all of these risks together
we need to do something else because
putting all these risks together is
creating
a a third risk
so you need to look at the overall risk
profile you need to look at at what all
these risks aggregated actually really
means for the project and what you can
do about it
not communicating risks and openly
discussing them
so this is back to the steering
committee meeting and what you're going
to do with what you identify a
leadership trait is that you are able
and that you are comfortable talking
about the real risks of the project
you know when you go into steering
committee meeting or when you write that
weekly
status report if i am a as an executive
i what do i want to see i want to see
your milestones that you're hitting your
milestones or if there's any risks
around hitting the milestones and then i
want to see an overview of your top
three to five risks and what you're
going to do about it and who owns it and
then i want to know
if you need any help from me as the
executive
so are there any risks that you need to
escalate to me
that's my concern as an executive as a
steering committee member or as a
sponsor i want to know what could go
wrong here
so don't try to hide the risks uh you
can also use your allies on the project
your senior stakeholders who are on
board use them to help you mitigate big
risks that you cannot deal with yourself
it's a great way to create
a stronger bond with your stakeholders
because they will know that you are on
to the right thing and that you can that
you're a good leader if you're really
good at highlighting and identifying and
mitigating the big risks of the project
now
let me share with you how you can lead a
risk workshop
because the risk workshop
is one of the quickest ways to creating
a collaborative risk culture and making
sure that you have
joint ownership of the risks
this picture here is actually from
shanghai
some years back where i went uh to run
some training out there and um
i thought it was a good action picture
here you can see that actually um
putting post-it notes on pieces of paper
and that's exactly what you should be
doing in a collaborative risk workshop
so i have four steps for you here
the first step is you get your team or
whoever is involved in this risk
workshop i i propose your core team
maybe with some outside people maybe
with some key
senior stakeholders who are very brought
into the pro to the project
you bring a stack of post-it notes or
sticky notes as the americans call them
and you have some
tape with you and you have some flip
chart paper
then you give every team member a stack
of sticky notes or post-it notes and you
ask them to identify anything that could
go wrong on this project one item per
post note that means one risk per
post-it note
at this point you're not filtering
anything you're good you're just getting
people to brainstorm
and then you put all of these uh sticky
notes up on the wall or up on a flip
chart so we look at what is it really
what are all these risks what is
everything that could go wrong risk to
do with
technology with people
with budgets with uh aligning the
product to strategy understanding user
needs all kinds of stuff that could go
wrong right when you cannot think of any
more you draw up the risk matrix that i
showed in under step 3 and 4.
you have likelihood on the horizontal
axis and impact on the vertical axis and
then you simply take each
post-it note at a time
and in collaboration you place it on the
matrix
you don't have to do
you actually don't have to participate
as a project manager you can be the
facilitator so imagine you have a flip
chart you've drawn this matrix on the
flip chart and one by one you take each
post-it note and say so people
team where we're going to place it
this is a risk
that um
[Music]
that's going to be hardware failure
right do we think there's a likelihood
of one two three do we think there's an
impact on one two three
no the likelihood is low okay it's low
likelihood of hardware failure if it
happens
um
it's a high impact so you put that on
the low likelihood and high impact and
that's how you go through all of the
post-it notes you are not steering the
process you should not dominate the
process you should let the team
agree where to put these post-it notes
that's how you get engagement so it's
very important that you're not too
controlling as a project manager let the
team do the work and you are simply the
facilitator moving post-it notes around
of course you can participate but you
you see what i'm saying don't be
controlling after you have placed all
the sticky notes on the uh in the chart
you take a marker pen can be any color
it doesn't have to be blue and you draw
a line where you feel the risk appetite
is of the project or of your
organization
again it's not you drawing it as a
project manager you ask your team
where are we gonna draw the line
just as a reminder what does the line
mean the line means that anything
towards the top right hand corner is
what you're going to do something about
they're all the risks that you're going
to look to
mitigate and to reduce and to avoid etc
anything
towards the bottom left hand corner
you're not going to do anything about
where you draw the line depends on the
risk appetite of your company and it
depends on the risk appetite of your
project can you afford for anything to
go wrong on your project so in
collaboration
you draw the line
the next step is then to draw the
risk register and you simply transfer
the post notes that were at the top
right hand corner of your chart
to the risk register you list what the
likelihood and impact was
let's say on a scale from one to one to
three
that means that your combined score l
times i the maximum score here is nine
you can use another scale
uh let's go back to this chart you can
use a scale from one to five
uh or whatever scale you want if you use
a scale from one to five
of course the maximum impact the
combined impact here likelihood and
impact is 25 so you can use any scale
you want this is just really to show
to give a way of
of quantifying
uh your risks
and looking at the severity
then as we said before you are going to
go through with your teams what are we
going to do about each of these risks
which response are we going to take are
we going to reduce it we're going to are
we going to
share it with a vendor
are we going to what are we going to do
but it's not enough to just write we're
going to reduce it no what are we
actually going to do to reduce the risk
are we going to run prototypes
to reduce the risk of
of untested technology delaying the
project or creating more work
and as you identify the actions here
remember
to look at two things how are we going
to lower the likelihood of the risk
that's the root cause
also what are we going to do to lower
the impact in
the risk happens there are two very
different types of risk responses that
you can reduce both of them
so as an example let's say you're
running that outdoor event that you are
running an outdoor concert and there's a
risk of rain
what are you going to do to lower the
root cause
of
your
um
of the rain where you can
the root cause is about rain you know
it's difficult to
all you can do is move it to a different
location move it to a season where it's
less likely to rain
what are you going to do to lower the
impact in case it does rain that's when
we can distribute umbrellas or ponchos
or put up a marquee
so i always want you to consider both of
these aspects good risk management means
that you
again going back to the to the
to the previous slide that you move the
risks down on both axis you lower the
likelihood and you lower the impact
okay then assigning owners you're doing
that in your risk work collaboratively
again it is not you as a risk as a
project manager saying
john i want you to own this risk
no it's not right
you list out all the actions and then in
collaboration we say who is the best
person to own this risk is someone in
this room able to own the risk or do we
need to draw someone else in
that is really the best way to get
collaboration to get buy-in to get
shared ownership so that you as a
product manager don't end up
owning all of the risks that's a very
important point
the date here is just a date by when the
action must be taken you can include
other fields in your risk list i've seen
very very uh long complicated risk lists
but really the at the minimum
you must write down what action you're
going to take and who owns the risk who
is responsible for making sure the
action happens that is the minimum that
you need to include in your risk
register
now
back to the management
versus leadership element here i want
you not just to go through the motions
of risk management i very much want you
to be leaders want to think and one of
the ways you can do that is to take what
i call a helicopter view take a step
back from your project on a regular
basis what's really going on here what
does your gut tell you do not
underestimate what your gut is telling
you are we on the right track
what are we missing out here what are we
not seeing
what have we forgotten about
what's the overall risk profile of the
project does this feel right or is there
something you know is my internal
navigation system telling me that
there's something we missed out
so it's very important that you can add
that leadership element taking a step
back removing yourself
from the process and just looking at it
observing it
maybe asking other people out there
from your experience what could go wrong
here what have we missed
and um
the last bullet here did you know that
risk can be estimated
and
and how do we do that
i say here in dollars pounds in in any
currency really but
you can add to your risk register an
amount
how do you calculate the amount of a
risk
let's say there is a
50 chance
that
technology is going to break down on
your pro that hardware is going to break
down let's make it simple there's a 50
chance that that's quite high by the way
50 charms that your hardware is gonna
fail it's a risk it's a big risk
then you say okay what's the cost in
case our hardware fails
well it's gonna cost us uh ten thousand
dollars if hardware fails it will cost
us ten thousand dollars to
fix it
okay because there's a fifty percent
likelihood the um cost of that risk is
of the 10 000 so that's 5 000
so you can go through each of your risks
look at how much it would cost you in
case that risk materialized
and then you just need to
times that
with the the probability if there's only
a 10 probability that a risk will
materialize then the cost of the risk is
of the impact i hope that makes sense
i haven't seen many people put that in
the risk list
but i think it's a good it can be a good
thing to do because when you add the
cost of all your risks up
you actually have a budget that you can
assign to your risks
so you see
it's not great to just go out to your
managers and say oh
we have some uncertainty on the project
let's put an extra contingency budget
that contingency should only be to cover
the unknown unknowns
i.e the risk you don't know about all
these other risks that you have in your
risk list you know about them you can
estimate them
so it's a really good way to quantify
your risks in in in dollar terms on
pound terms or whatever
um to make it more material and to say
what what what's what's the real impact
in uh in financial terms
of our risks
one last thing because before we wrap up
and again thank you to all of you who
are stayed on i know that we're going
over time because we have some issues
earlier on with the sound so i do
appreciate all of you who are hanging on
there
one last thing
what is your own personal risk attitude
and why on earth am i asking about that
because
some people
some project managers
have a high risk appetite you gladly
take risks
and that will impact
your risk appetite on a project
other people are very very risk averse
they hate risks and they want to go with
belts and braces as we say in english
they want to uh check and double check
and make sure we've thought about
everything they're overly conservative
if that's your risk attitude again that
will impact your behavior you're going
to be very very conservative and risk
averse on your project
again that impacts your risk culture
so i'm bringing this up because you need
to be aware of how your own risk
attitude is affecting the way that you
come across on your project
if you are a very
risk-averse person who is working for an
organization who love to take risks
then you may be overly conservative
maybe you may be too conservative for
your project and that would impact
the way that risk management happens
so there is no right or wrong here
i'm simply bringing this to your
attention because i would like you to be
aware
of your own impact on this process
are you uncomfortable with risks are you
okay with risks and how does that fit in
does it conflict or does it complement
the risk appetite of your company and of
your organization
if you love to take risks then maybe you
need to be a little bit more stringent
when it comes to risk management on your
project because
maybe you
are not wanting to see all the risk
because your personal profile is such
that you like to accept risks so i
really just bring this up to make you
aware
that you do impact uh risks and
risk culture in your company and i just
want you to be aware of how you are
doing that
just a very brief summary
some of the key takeaways
do involve people do have collaborative
risk workshops that you are running that
is very very fundamental to a good uh
risk management process so that you can
begin to create a risk culture
listen to your god instinct be a leader
take a step back
does this make sense are we on the right
track what have we not thought about
so important this is not just about
following a process risk management is
really about leadership it's about
leading your team
through unchartered territory
remember the positive risks there are
opportunities
things that might happen such as new
technology coming along whilst you
already have locked yourself into
technology choices how can you leverage
new technology on the fly that's a
positive risks it could be beneficial if
you are ready and agile enough to
embrace it but that needs to be talked
about and thought about in advance
never ignore the important risks and
always talk about them discuss important
risks
with your senior stakeholders with your
sponsor
especially in the steering committee
meetings is going to make you stand out
as someone who is in control who knows
what they're doing and who's not afraid
of talking about the things that could
really
impact the project
and always assign owners to risks not
just yourself please
we looked at the nine step risk
management process identifying risks
analyzing root causes
determining impact on probability
deciding on the right risk response this
is where you look at either reducing the
risk accepting the risk transferring it
or sharing it
and always look at how you can lower the
impact of a risk as well as the
likelihood
assigning owners in collaboration we've
talked about at length
documenting risks in your risk register
communicating them through weekly
reports
and in the
monthly steering committee meetings if
you have such steering committee
meetings which i'm hoping
and finally regularly review the risks
that is a summary of everything we went
through
what did you take from this please go
back over your notes and capture your
learning points what are you going to do
differently as a result of this are you
going to start running collaboratively
collaborative risk workshops with
post-it notes or sticky notes and
where you are the facilitator i think
your team will enjoy being involved
they'll enjoy being asked what they feel
could go wrong in the project
as i said before you can gain access to
all of my resources for free on my
website
suzannemadison.com or
suzannematson.co.uk it will take you to
exactly the same place
there will be one of the tabs called
resources when you click on the
resources tab you can register
to get access to my resources
for free completely for free there's
lots of templates for you to download
one of them is a risks and an issues log
right and that is my website once again
suzannemadison.com or susan matson.co.uk
i have both of those domain names
with that having said we are concluding
the webinar thank you thank you for your
patience thank you thank you for those
of you who are holding on
please go to my website sandmadson.com
if you want to know more
also connect with me on linkedin and on
twitter
my twitter id suzannemadin.com
if you want to know more and being a be
a project leader i i do encourage you to
get hold of my latest uh book the power
project leadership which as i said very
excitingly is actually being translated
to chinese as we speak
anything else connect with me on twitter
or linkedin feel free to ask questions
feel free to use all of the resources on
my own website susan madison.com and i
cannot thank you enough for having
stayed throughout this webinar and
having been patient with us
um thank you so much this concludes the
webinar from today
have a great rest of your wednesday bye
bye
you